on this episode I talk about the Apple
watch setting goals and I get deep hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode 16 fun fact about the number 16
I dislike the number santiago asks what
do you think about the Apple watch
Santiago I uh I've been here in Atlantic
City all weekend did not watch the
performance so I actually know very
little about the Apple watch I think
it's kind of ironic that Steve's asking
me this question but I chose to answer
it and here's why
I'm gonna ask I'm gonna answer it
philosophically I actually didn't see
all the bells and whistles I literally
know nothing about the Apple watch I saw
like some random picture in a Twitter
feed but here's what I do know this
becomes this this becomes this and then
this becomes this we are absolutely 100%
going robotic and I mean over the course
of the next hundred plus years and so
the evolution of information being
closer to us started something that's
like there's one further like you go
back and involve to something that was
always on us now it's gonna be kind of
like even closer like not even going in
the pocket google ass and things of that
nature I think underrated I think more
of that kind of stuff is coming as well
and so I think it's evolution the human
evolution
hey Gary how's it going my name is adore
you Dec I make youtube videos and I
created the Twitter account OMG facts
now I control and manage a network of
many different accounts on many
different social platforms and my
question for you today is do you believe
creating my own website with valuable
original content to drive traffic to is
a reasonable investment for long term
branding what do you believe that
websites are going to be irrelevant
eventually with this mobile revolution
that's happening should I be looking
more into app development or something
that I'm not even looking at let me know
thanks yeah I think it's a really good
question a lot of people are struggling
with I will say this you know I have
garyvaynerchuk.com Oh
get out anyway I've garyvaynerchuk.com
for a reason not for kicks and giggles I
want to have a platform that I
fundamentally control all aspects of and
so you know when you are building brand
on Twitter with a bunch of Twitter
accounts like you are like I am when
you're building a Facebook fan page you
know some Facebook themes for itself and
for its audience and for you believe it
or not that they need to drop down
organic reach and everything they're
putting out is not being delivered you
start understanding why having your own
email service having your own website
matters having your own app matters if
you deem that people are going to spend
more of their time within the app than
on a mobile native website just because
the world's going mobile or risky or or
this you know or virtual reality doesn't
necessarily mean that the website is
gone it's really just a protocol for a
place that you can own and so what I
would say is philosophically you want to
have your own house but doing business
in your vacation home or in a hotel also
matter if you understood that analogy
you're on your way Kyle asked do you set
and track personal business goals aside
from owning the Jets what do you find
useful in the process you know I really
don't set any business goals other than
to continue to gain leverage you know
pay for provide value to the audience
make money keep it practical and
ambitious but I don't have a goal of
like I'm gonna get vaynermedia to 100
million and then this is gonna happen or
the fund is gonna return three times its
twenty five million dollar investment at
vayner/rse and then this will happen or
in four years I'm gonna get into the car
wash business I just don't go that route
my route is really my fundamental play
is I always talk about my one goal being
the jetsam fertile hard core people that
followed my career I'm gonna throw a
little bit of a curveball to you give
you a little more fun fact that's kind
of thing that I want to do with the show
the only other Bowl or strategy I have
is collecting people you know finding
the individuals that I think I can jam
with for the next 15 20 30 45 years
professionally that to me is the is the
global strategy who can I do business
with as a
mate forever what's up Gary so um you
know I just quit my job at radio after
being on air since I was 16 years old it
kind of risks everything for this new -
radio app I hope you've checked it out
you guys tell me a favorite station but
what was the riskiest thing you've ever
done in your career because it was tough
for me to leave something I've been in
for so long especially an institution
like traditional radio in order to try
something new with zero listeners today
disrupt that industry what was the
toughest choice you ever made in your
life or in business about leaving
something that you've done to do
something there you know again the
enormous excitement I have behind doing
this show and thank you all for allowing
me to do this show is predicated on the
fact that I get to tell you things
you've never heard before I'm gonna say
something that I never ever ever ever
ever ever have talked about before which
is the toughest professional thing I've
ever done my cliche answer historically
has been you know leaving the Wine
Library which is my first love and
that's a very big truth but as I've
started becoming a little bit more in
tune with my own feelings and and have
given this thought the toughest thing I
ever had to do and Steve path of genuine
like this answer the toughest thing I
ever had to do believe it or not was
make the decision that I was okay with
putting myself out there it you know a
lot of you probably have at this point
forgotten because the Gary Vee persona
and narrative has taken over my career
in my Wikipedian thinks in that nature
but the first 10 to 15 articles that
have ever been written about me in the
AP in the New York Times in the Wall
Street Journal was wizkid bills business
that the establishment the business
world the people that I look up to it in
ways maybe not specifically because they
don't really have heroes but like
respect their their opinions and and
their accomplishments I went from the
narrative of being a great business
operator that sought friends and
executed it for financial gain which is
like something everybody deems to be so
noble in business to being
self-promoter to being a social media
guru to being an author making the
decision that I could accept the rolling
of the eyes of the Ivy League grads or
the establishment to get bigger reach to
build audience to jam with people to be
human than extroverted and taking that
step back or two or three in the minds
of the top two or three percent was a
pretty interesting difficult decision
for me knowing what the consequences
were of putting myself out there and
that I would be respected unless for my
business accomplishments because of it
wasn't the easiest thing that I ever had
to deal with and something that's very
honestly I still continue to deal with I
know this is where you start getting
into I don't know if you want to get dog
but this is when you start getting into
the darkness of it in a weird way it's I
like the underestimation that comes
along with it as well because the truth
is the reason that entrepreneurship and
business speaks to me especially in an
American context is that the truth is
undefeated that ultimately you know if I
go and execute multiple hundred million
dollar businesses and make smart
investments it's all net net right like
you may not like the fact that I don't
dress up or that I curse onstage or that
I self promote or whatever you want to
call it but if I execute you just have
to eat it and so that was clearly DJ
that was clearly the toughest thing for
me which was that I was consciously
self-aware that I was entering a realm
where I would start becoming more
disrespected even though my
accomplishments were gonna be greater
that Mis positioning was something that
uh I was tough question of the day let's
just actually know what that was such a
profound question question they what is
the hardest thing you ever had you
professionally because let's be honest
there's we're waiting for things of
raising a child with a disability or or
bankruptcy or or pain or a lot of
emotional stuff so in the context of
business once
toughest business challenge that you've
ever had to deal with you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them